so one of the things that really
surprised me about the show is this is
um more violent than I expected thumbs
up but it believe me um so it's more
like Netflix than Disney plus which I'm
all in on that so can you sort of talk
about the aspect that it's a more mature
version of a Marvel show yeah I think
it's a great question you know I think I
think everything sort of stemmed first
and foremost from the story right like
we we knew we wanted to tell a story
about my Lopez um that was you know it
was always going to be a little more
grounded a little more gritty on the
gritty side a little more street level
um but to me the most interesting aspect
about the character is that in Hawkeye
she is a villain you know and um in the
conversations with Marvel early on uh
the response was like let's lean into
that let's see if we can push the
envelope let's see how far down that
rabbit hole we can go and take that
character and you know I think for me
one of the most fascinating things to to
ask myself was like how does a deaf
indigenous girl from Oklahoma become a
top ranking lieutenant in kingpin's Army
you know um and and and so that that as
a jumping off point sort of Lent itself
to you know the tone which is you know
because we're because we're telling
something that's a little more intimate
and because there are real world
consequences that means that people die
people get killed people bleed uh bones
break you know spoilers for Echo but
bones get broken and so um you know all
of that sort of came about naturally
like you know it wasn't you know we
didn't necessarily have a conversation
of like oh do we want to do Netflix or
Disney plus it was just I would say it
was Marvel giving us the creative
freedom to to try to tell the best story
possible uh so I'm fascinated by the
editing process because it's where it
all comes together so how did echko
change in the editing room in ways that
you guys did not expect oh wow yeah TR
you know I will say Marvel is positively
Fearless when it comes to storytelling
uh and that applies to the edit process
you know um you know I've worked on
I've been able to work on uh you know TV
shows and and there there are shows I've
worked on that are you know you shoot
what's on the page and you uh you do not
deviate from that and so in this case
you know we shot our episodes and we put
the episodes together and then and then
you know my uh collaborators you know
and Marvel Executives and everything
then we got in and we proceeded to sort
of uh uh just try stuff and blow stuff
up um and really explore different story
permutations so um how much did it
change it changed quite a bit did you
end up with like a lot of deleted scenes
things really radically like you know
what I mean like I like learning about
okay it was originally going to be this
but now it's this yeah I you know AB yes
yes things things change and they always
do it's it's interesting like when I uh
when I every every every project that
I've been able to both write direct and
edit on it's it's very you go through
this interesting sort of evolution like
what's the expression that you have
three rewrites right it's script it's a
production and it's post and
um and so with this we had the scripts
and I was like oh this is the story
there is no fat on these things this is
going to be one to one and you get in
you shoot it and things change you're
open the inspiration that comes about on
the day um and then you make little
tweaks and adjustments and in some cases
massive adjustments you know um where we
had to again like just shooting in the
time of covid there were circumstances
where we had to rewrite on the Fly um
and then uh and then I think and then in
the edit too as well too then it was
looking at like hey what tells the best
possible story and it was we we would
just pull out threads here pull out
threads there try rearranging stuff um
and and everything just sort of came
about organically but it was it yeah
massive difference from the beginning to
the end so um no spoilers but when I was
watching the first three episodes
episode three ends with um uh I'm just
going to say I'll save this or whatever
but episode three ends with Kingpin uh
and Kingpin has an an eye patch and uh I
think I noticed possibly some tech
underneath the bandage but you know you
don't really see it is there anything
you want to tease about any sort of tech
I will say any any Tech in our show uh
is in line with our our theme in our
tone which is grounded street level uh
lowii got it uh one of the things that's
really cool is this is under the
spotlight umbrella and which is awesome
and can you sort of talk about what that
means for people that don't know and
maybe what you're excited for Marvel you
know what you're excited as a fan for
Marvel to be to do yeah I I think the I
think there's a tremendous amount of
Freedom that comes with the spotlight
Banner right so the the spotlight
Spotlight means you don't have to have
seen 23 other MCU films or have seen
like six other series before this um uh
and we we want specifically to invite
people in who who don't have that
familiarity and and hopefully they can
come in and watch our show and our
series uh uh and and just jump right in
from the beginning uh but on the same
token uh viewers who are familiar with
with the MCU we'll uh in you know in
multiple episodes we'll see um uh
characters that they they recognize from
other films and in series as well too so
hopefully it's the best of both worlds
with streaming you really don't have
like a mandate for runtime so I'm just
curious did was there was everyone sort
of like we want the episodes to be about
40 minutes or you know what I mean like
how did you guys decide ultimately how
long the episodes would be yeah again it
it's so interesting because it it was it
was a very organic process you know
um I think I think what what is a
network hour long it's like 42 minutes
something like that well it also depends
on are you yeah it could be somewhere
around there let's say 42 let's say 42
minutes and and it wasn't our intent but
our run times for our episodes end up
being around that so it was this I wish
I could say it was intentional but it
was sort of a happy accident last
question for you uh you see the shooting
schedule what is the thing you have
circled in terms of I cannot wait to
film this or oh my God how are we going
to film this oh wow um
you know it's interesting because the
the you know I would say the thing that
I was
both excited and terrified to shoot was
the ASL right because you know going
into the process going into the process
you know you ask yourself the question
like how can we sustain a three four
five six minute conversation between a
character or multiple characters who
don't speak um and so that was a big
question for myself going in and then
with my cinematographer we're fing how
do we do this how do we go about this um
can we even do this and the answer is
yes and so and I'll say you know one of
if not my favorite scenes in the entire
uh Series without spoiling it is a is a
scene between two characters where not a
single word spoken for multiple minutes
um and it's it brings me to tears every
time I see it yeah I I really did enjoy
that um in some of the anyway I won't
say specifically congrats really hope
it's a huge hit for you guys and thank
you for your time thank
you